she is our basically our Muse and we
love this woman you'll love the Vega on
the podcast would be a great get we want
to get Yolanda Vega on this podcast we'd
like to maybe she could even do this
you're friends with her if your family
with her we'd love to get Yolanda on yes
if you're a friend or family member of
Yolanda Vega this and if you don't know
her since I'm a young person uh this is
the woman who draws the New York State
lottery numbers and she has a little
calling card and this is what she says
you ready for this
isn't that amazing or the best
I think
I love you do you think I love you too
do you think that she came up with that
or you think like she was just on the
air one day I saw a parent's name
[Laughter]
no I think that she probably just I
don't know like she's a broadcaster in a
sense right she just did it so I'm
Yolanda Vega if you're from New York
there's nothing it's that says New York
as a bodega she is as new that saying is
New York through and through you can
actually and it's probably at times must
be tough to be here because when she
walks she's the type of person
she's walking through the streets I
would say a hundred times a day people
are yelling Yolanda Vega
uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
thanks to my husband Miguel I am hey
we got it a dream has come true
you are the first guest Miss Vega yes
you're the first guest that we said out
loud oh my God we wish we can get
everyone here and we just threw it out
into the universe a year ago a year ago
we threw it out it was 2021 one of my
co-workers Sandra at the lottery came
over to me may actually and she said hey
they're playing uh in in Albany you want
to come see the show Sal loves you no
offense Chris yeah I got it and I said
no I can't but what's going on she says
can you make an autograph for him and I
did so I will let's we have a lot to go
through yeah we have a lot to go through
let's do it I received this
beautiful and I brought this on someone
I'm so sorry that the God who gave me
this Sandra
but but I I Sandra do I know Sandra
probably not but someone she handed it
to someone gave me this and I'm I'm
sorry I forgot who it was I really am
but I was always like I wonder if this
is real because you know I I just came
to me from nowhere and I'm like it looks
real and it says hi Sal vulcano and it's
got a dollar sign up at the top love it
it says hope to meet you uh when you win
good luck best regards Yolanda Vega 2021
the PS you cracked me up and I was like
I can't believe that I brought this on
I'm like the queen has responded
before this what you mean to New Yorkers
and I think you know that the big you're
you're uh and you know as especially the
New Yorkers you know my children are are
Puerto Rican so so you know as Puerto
Ricans
um we only there's only two people who I
want my daughters to be either Yolanda
Vega or Fat Joe that's and and those are
you are the two king and queen Porter
New York Puerto Rican so it's an honor
it is yes thank you and you are Puerto
Rican I am boricua okay mom and dad born
in Puerto Rico
um
yes oh that's I was born and raised in
Brooklyn okay uh Sunset Park Red Hook
Bank
I tell people I'm from Bay Ridge I'm not
so Red Hook baby Red Hook I love Red
Hook they got a good Ikea now they do
now
I can Red Hook Tavern has a great burger
you said what parts of Puerto Rico
um that's where my grandma's from oh my
God yeah yeah on the west coast yes wow
yeah look at unpirculating that's how
excited I am
that's literally where her entire
family's from she's from 100 Puerto
Rican uh my Grandma Lilly Diaz and uh
and then shout out Lydia Diaz
493 no she's 91 or 94. we don't okay my
daddy's cousin you think so yeah
probably from over there right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so so yes so we have a
kinship to you and actually I used to
live with my grandparents uh those those
grandparents and every single night we'd
watch like they'd have their they'd have
their like routine and they'd watch like
Wheel of Fortune and and right at that
time I think it was seven o'clock 7 30.
or 7 30 yeah and so we'd speed watch you
every night you know so we grew up on
you so this is a big deal for us is what
we're saying big huge deal literally
part of New York history and um do you
know Yolanda that with the lottery we
wanted to ask you about this because we
talk about this a lot the lottery
winners are cursed whoever wins the
lotto they they they literally they
usually die within two or three years or
they go broke what do you think do you
have any tips for people gonna win the
lotto out there no way first of all
that's very very sad because that's just
you get the negative stories there are a
lot of good stories of lottery winners
out there yeah somebody bought his and
her jet skis yes like and let me add the
biggest lottery winner of all time Mr
Vega who got to marry you that's what
I'd like to say thank you I know how to
talk to my Puerto Ricans
I say I hit the jackpot when I started
the job I started the job in 90 February
1990 and Miguel and I had been married
four years and we've been trying to have
kids and it wasn't happening right and
he's a state trooper and I worked for
New York State Lottery and I said you
know what um I was working doing
accounting so I was working at a Bagel
Company
um so we were doing accounting for a
bagel yeah I had my degree from Hunter
College in economics from Hunter College
she works for us
it is
this week she ordered me a chocolate m m
suit
if you work upstairs Albany because I'm
born and raised in New York City
Brooklyn for like 30 years and then he
married me he says I'm a State Trooper
in Albany so you marry me you gotta move
to Albany and I was like take me away so
took me away and you left the bagels I
left no I left working for a restaurant
down here on 9th and 41st in Manhattan
up to Bruegger's Bagels health kit yeah
okay up to bruga's Bagels up in Albany
and I was doing Dairy County work when
the job knocked on my door for being a
lottery person so I'll tell you about
that in a second but we trained us on so
um we've been trying to have kids and it
was four years we were married and I
started at the lottery and she in
February of 1990 and in May of 1990 we
got pregnant wow so we hit the lottery
we hit the jackpot yes yes your
beautiful daughter who we just my other
beautiful daughter Gabriella who is 32
and Rebecca is turning 31 in two days
wow oh you got Irish twins
I love it yes and before we forget
Rebecca is getting married to Matt at in
9124 Now Matt is my little Gringo from
Long Island yes and he's marrying a
little boy you know full bodyqua so he's
becoming another he's becoming me he's a
little crazy
and we're gonna we're gonna talk him
through it and we will get it here
we're gonna talk
um but so wait a second so that means so
you would so this whole time you know
when we would see you as as growing up
on the new uh you know reading lottery
numbers you were traveling from Albany
every day to New York City to read those
numbers no the numbers were drawn in the
Albany area
see I never knew that did you know that
yeah did you know that no idea I thought
you were in Manhattan yeah shout outs
connect wow we have Regional Offices
sales offices everywhere but the
drawings were up in Schenectady okay wow
okay so you said the job knocked at your
door yes explain okay so I was working
doing Accounting in the in the bagel
place yeah and um also another
restaurant so I went from this regular
restaurant called cranberry bog which
doesn't exist anymore okay to the bagel
place and when I was at the cranberry
bog going to the bagel place someone
said to me hey um the lottery is looking
for someone to do drawings at night um
work in the evening announce the winning
numbers would you like to do it Yolanda
A friend of mine Francis and I said I
don't have any experience I've never
been on the radio or the TV I don't
think so oh my goodness I couldn't do it
oh come on audition so I auditioned the
day I went to audition there remember I
was already 34 years old and they were
well you are queen and a goddess I just
don't say that you were wearing the same
outfit as your bobblehead which thank
you for that I love red and black yes
love it so I go for the audition as all
these young girls and I said to myself
oh my God I don't stand a chance in hell
and being selected so I went up there I
was is my normal Yolanda Vega self and
they chose me sure because you you
exuded you you gave them the yellow I
didn't have that at the time
okay that develops six months later oh
really you know how how he's going to
tell us how she developed Yolanda Vega
what happened I'm sorry you know how it
developed yes how I started people ask
me how do you did you think give it a
lot of thought consciously unconsciously
I I drink espresso coffee and I drink a
lot of espresso coffee you know that
Puerto Rican coffee
that morning I drank a lot so we're
still in training and I get up there and
the the director producer has a stop
clock a stopwatch and he's like go and I
said for the New York Lottery I'm
Yolanda Vega at the time and uh but I
really stretched my name out and he says
that's too long you're killing too many
seconds with your name you got a short
note and I hope he's in a ditch
somewhere right now he doesn't know what
he's that's the whole Essence I said to
him no I can't do that because that's
who I am that's who I feel inside that's
who I'm gonna project love this and I
kept it and I really kept it because it
got longer
yeah longer longer longer longer longer
and anyway the rest is history and then
you got it wow you stay true to who you
were that's a good lesson kids I mean
someone else in you in that position if
it wasn't you I don't think would have
had that trajectory and the impact that
you've had I guarantee you because of
your personality and the bubbliness and
that fun and how people kind of like you
in that way I guarantee you you are
responsible directly for extra sales
and and to stick to who she is the
cajones it takes for you to say you know
what because you could have easily been
influenced by this person who said you
basically trying to tell you hey you'll
get the job if you listen to me you said
no Fu I'm gonna do what I want to do and
then you got the job anyway absolutely I
love it in spite of a good lesson to
stick true to who you are and everybody
needs to think about right now everyone
needs to activate their little Yolanda
Vegas that live inside them yes if
you're at a job somewhere and someone
requests something of you that you don't
like you say to them [__] you yeah and
excuse my language don't don't please
Let It Fly oh okay you say to them hey
fudge you and I'm gonna do what I want
and I think everything will be fine yeah
you say F no I don't care who you are
whatever you say F you I'm gonna do what
I want and this is your London God you
walk away that's true now your maiden
name yes is for 30 years I'm Yolanda
antequera or in English Yolanda and
taquera and let's see how it sounds can
we do one test with Yolanda and takera
and see if it sounds good ready four and
thanks to my husband Miguel I am Yolanda
antiqueror no
but I need you give me you in it
there's something about Vega is I'm a v
last name so I I don't know yeah yeah
yeah yeah well this is I believe so so
so that was just were your
responsibilities are limited to driving
in getting out going into the building
walking into the door hitting the button
calling the numbers and then driving
back home oh everybody thought it was a
30 second job okay I would go on
promotions I'd ride parades
their parade yes absolutely I would Long
Island and work with the Long Island
Ducks at a promotion out there and
finally baseball team yeah it was I just
became it consumed that this became the
job this became the full-time job yeah
and then it was a lot of press
conferences that were thrown in after
um came after I would go and present the
checks and do the whole house let me ask
you at the height of it all let's talk
let's let's go 1995. right let's we're
at the height right now were you getting
stopped all day every day in your daily
life well let's go to 1994. let's get to
94 then in 1994 Oprah Winfrey did an
anchorwoman makeover and she asked for
Roz Abrams the anchor woman from chapter
seven to appear and she went to Florida
and Texas and California picked all
these anchor women well Roz couldn't
appear and because we were on channel 7
at the time they said what about Yolanda
Vega and her producers said who's that
and they said
she announces the lottery numbers in New
York state and they're like yeah she's
not looking for a lottery analysis they
said look take this DVD or whatever they
had at the time and let Oprah see it yes
when Oprah when we sat down because I
did up here on her show when we sat down
she said and you know I saw you or your
opening and I seen you from New York
state state because I'd go to New York
State and see you on TV and I said I
definitely want her so I was seen on the
Oprah Winfrey Show in the anchor woman
makeover and after 1994 October then you
couldn't walk down the street without
people knowing who I was that was oh
thank you yeah after that was well
all right wow so it is because because
it's one of those things where I don't
know anyone else who's been able to make
this job
Infamous like you have like there's all
famous famous sorry is is the only other
person we ever could think of is the is
the New York State Lotto guy uh the the
lotto guy we don't even know his name
the commercial the name of face who
would put the thing up to his face and
announced the lottery winners at the end
or announced the lotto jackpot this like
in the late 90s that's the only other
person I don't think any other state
knows who the hell is reading their
lives besides New York we would we were
just pontificating that guy might be
also in a ditch somewhere because it
might be dead we just saw a commercial
of 99 it's 24 years later we don't know
who that guy is where he is do you know
who that guy is his name is Ralph whoa
um allegedly
[Applause]
and he was a paid actor I'm a state
employee or was a state employee I got
paid State wages he got paid actors oh I
hope he's in a ditch somewhere he got
paid okay wow so it was funny because
every time I'd go around and give away
Millions people would look at me and
like oh my God she's a millionaire no
I'm not a millionaire I just give away
Millions
seriously so yeah his name was Ralph and
you can just see this part of him yeah
and then after one part I think so many
years later they decided let's drop that
campaign campaign or what happened yeah
yeah they should have given it to you
why would they not do that it's like
with The Daily Show just give it to Roy
Wood Junior boy everybody everybody by
the way Yolanda Vega born May 26 1956
Queens New York you know who was born
May 24 1956 in Queens New York my mother
you might have been in the same hospital
as my mother that is wrong
Ralph did this you've been watching
Wikipedia right yeah that is all wrong I
was born December 10th in Brooklyn New
York I won't tell you the year but it is
1955.
my dad's birthday is December
45 but yes but still December 10 1955 is
when I was born and raised Brooklyn oh
time for the lottery so that's the that
that sound means it's time to draw some
lottery numbers yes here we go
representing me so we just open that up
first she's going to pick up open that
up three we're gonna pick out three
lottery balls and you're just gonna read
them out the first ball up the second
ball up third ball okay you ready yes
and you know this is not the way it was
done that's reaching into a bit
he's 50.
it's 63.60
how much did the lottery numbers go up
to well the the numbers were three
digits and four digits and then there's
Lotto which is six numbers right but how
many how but what do those numbers go up
this could be Mega and power okay so
we're still okay this is this is what we
want is that by the end of this all of
our all of our viewers we want them to
go out and play these numbers and the
next number is one number one
63 and one and one more all right
final number is
62. wow literally you just enacted Sal's
fantasy of Yolanda Vega pulling Lottery
balls out of his lap
you were pulling on Sal's Lottery balls
yes uh that I mean I can't believe this
is happening this is literally Sal is in
heaven right now so am I what numbers
today we are going to go play them in
the lottery and you are going to be
included in that ticket and if we win
three between but you have to add more
yeah no we're gonna we're gonna do it
throughout the show and then if we win
here's the thing if we win we're gonna
in order to get you the money that Rob
stole from you we're gonna split it
three ways that's right we're gonna
switch
three ways with you and this is to
combat thieving Ralph yes little [__]
ways and we don't know where he is but
he took the whole pot and he ran yeah
and now now he he needs to come up the
name of this episode is Ralph sucks
oh my god wow what's it like giving
giving a check of millions of dollars to
families and things like that what is
that like to to know like is is it the
same type of feeling every time because
like they probably it must be amazing it
is you know
that's that's right no no no no first of
all when I got the job in 90 1990 my mom
resta Soul was still alive okay my mom
was a big time Lottery player numbers
win four when we would go to her house
before I worked at the lottery she said
so when I got the job and I was on
camera and all I saw was that camera and
everything else was docked I'd imagine
my mom in that camera so when I said
those winning numbers they were with
love for Mom it comes across and now it
kind of turned around not now but at the
same time it turned around when I would
meet the winners the millionaires I'm
like you're like my mom that you just
won Millions I'm so happy from you from
my heart from my soul I mean I'm so
happy for you and that's the same
feeling whether they want a million
whether they won 460 million I'm so
happy do you know your biggest jackpot
that you get I don't even recall was
over 300 or something million wow but
did you meet that person do you you were
there with them at a press conference I
have my hand around them because they're
nervous and shaking we talk an hour
before we used to talk an hour before
and we'd get little you know um things
understood and then I'd make present
them to everyone who media now if I was
someone who won the lottery and I won
anyway which in many ways you have Sal
in many ways we've won the lottery have
I won 20 million 40 million if I won 300
million I I know it's probably not
allowed but I would find a way on the
side
to break you off a piece
did anyone not get out anyone ever
accepted it's got to be a way that we
can get around this somebody wants to
break you off a mill you could be like I
quit and then just take it no but then
they'd find that I took it and it's
wrong and I love my job so I wanted to
stay at the library so there was none of
those Shenanigans I could give it to
your husband as a gift he is also
related to me he couldn't even play the
lottery when the boys at the trooper
station were playing I'm giving it to
math you give it to Matt I'll give it to
Matt
he's not in the family yet but I wanted
to tell you um not in the family yet
what I wanted to tell you was um a lot
of people when they when you asked me
this earlier about winning and so many
people have lost it
which is finally you
become an anonymous anonymous anonymous
anonymous yes and you can claim
anonymity that's the word I'm trying to
find yes and that way you change all
your phone numbers you disappear
somewhere otherwise you're going to be
hounded people are coming at you from
every angle and then it gets nasty
because family members people start
coming out of the woodwork you actually
become a Target where this way you
become Anonymous you can do it and you
can do it anonymously and then this way
if you want to break off you'll want to
make a little piece they don't know
where that money came from she got a
good investment in fidelity
but in the state of New York weather at
this point I don't know I don't work for
them anymore whether they have the law
of anonymity active or not okay because
it was up on the table you can create an
LLC sure and not give away your identity
I love it that's what you see that's the
way to do it you've heard it here first
if you win because yes you because you
know you're right we only tend to think
about the big lottery winners the three
400 Millions but there's many people
that win though people are winning a
lottery do people win it every day like
in some small amount or no oh absolutely
is every single
single Big Five there's so many games
out you you have UF with the
scratch-offs now when I was working for
the lottery yeah 32 years you couldn't
I'd have to go to Vegas to gamble yeah
or Jersey
um but the ponies yeah the Foxwoods or
whatever oh sure sure no problem I don't
like classes though Atlantic City
Atlanta Atlantic City but more Vegas My
grandmother used to take the bus down to
Atlantic City to go to Resorts World
it's fun and just play with the buckets
of coin slots all day long but now I can
play right and I can now you've become a
degenerate Gambler no no no
but there was a new game at one point
soon after I left the lottery and I was
buying it with ten dollar tickets and I
won 500. I would have thought I won five
million and you don't have to claim that
600 and up you got to claim right there
it is
there you go how about this coming and
play Quick Draw too that's another thing
we win the lotto Yolanda Vega for the
rest of her life is getting deposits to
595 we don't know where it came from we
don't have to play Nobody Knows It
doesn't matter
yeah what's up babe listen the only
tickets I have left are May 6th in
Ithaca New York the State Theater of
Ithaca May 6 we got a few tickets left
and then uh September 22nd New York City
Radio City is sold out so we've added
September 23rd to theater at Madison
Square Garden New York City those
tickets are almost sold out too so go
get your tickets but everywhere else
Buffalo Albany Newport Rhode Island it's
all sold out christycomedy.com for
tikiwickies
all right guys here we go tonight I'm in
Bangor Maine tonight at the Cross
Insurance Center this weekend we're at
the Wang theater for three in Boston uh
next week we're in West Valley Utah and
the Bellco Theater in Denver Colorado uh
May 19th we're doing Texas Arlington
Texas Austin Texas at the Moody Center
Sugar Land Texas at the Smart Center uh
Financial Center May 21st June we're in
Columbus Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis
Des Moines Kansas City uh July we got
Nashville Indianapolis and St Louis
they're all on sale right now at
impracticaljokerslive.com this tour has
been so much fun we always have
different openers and surprise guests
get your tickets uh tonight is the half
season finale of impractical jokes on
TBS at 10 o'clock uh with Blake Anderson
is the guest star of Workaholics Fame
and other stuff so check that out and go
to get shipfaced cruise.com to see with
uh what we are doing with Eric Andre
very soon I love you all and uh thank
you so much for that
bye March
what is Hello fresh America's number one
milk yeah well what is it with hello
fresh you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store and count on
hello fresh to make home cooking fun
easy and affordable that's why it's
America's Numero Uno meal kits flavor is
in full bloom at hellofresh enjoy the
taste of spring with Chef crafted
recipes featuring ripe seasonal
ingredients delivered right to your door
hellofresh does more than just delicious
dinners by the way not only can you take
your pick from 40 weekly recipes but you
can choose from over 100 items to round
out your order from snacks and easy
lunches to desserts and Pantry
Necessities everything arrives in one
box on a delivery day YouTube and this
may hello fresh is celebrating Asian
American and Pacific Islander Heritage
Month try limited time authentic recipes
created in partnership with Chef serbi
Sani of New York City's Thai tag Mo I'm
sorry that's there's a lot of different
words and I got them right yes
restaurant and enjoy a cultural taste
tour right in your own kitchen check
save money if you're growing to-do list
with hellofresh it's 25 percent cheaper
than takeouts and we're going to make it
even cheaper for you if you just go to
hellofresh.com hey babe16 and use the
code hey babe 16 you're going to get 16
free meals plus free shipping okay let's
say that again like we do hellofresh.com
hey babe16 use the code hey babe 16 16
female free meals plus free shipping I
mean how could you not be ordering it
right now we are long time used to
fellow fresh ever since they came on
board we love it hellofresh is America's
number one meal kit babe
babe yes babe
here we go when you were a kid yes did
somebody read Everybody Poops by Taro
gomi to you uh are you kidding me let's
just say many adults have forgotten the
details poop anxiety self-controlled
constipation right a nervous diary are
conditions many adults experience
throughout their lives but at the end of
the day it's just poop it's just poop
sounds like a day in the life you're
right and seeds ds01 registered
trademark makes it Go makes it easier to
go babe let me tell you something when I
get nervous I just cannot poop or
sometimes when I get nervous I'm pooping
like you can't imagine
but what seeds dso1 does is it keeps me
regular it's a symbiotic which means
it's a Prebiotic and a probiotic which
is unheard of it's unheard in this day
and age and and it literally it promotes
Digestive Health to support Health
irregularity or the ease of bloating it
also ease of evacuation it reinforces
healthy stool hydration which is nice
you want you I want my shoes
they're doing yoga 16 of the 24 strains
are specifically geared towards
digestive health and that makes sense
people take a probiotic for Digestive
Health it promotes digestive health and
again it supports gutties from
occasional gastrointestinal discomfort
associated with increased intestinal
Transit you don't want it now I want to
give you guys an offer right here
because it's really
and sustainable packaging with a
reusable collection she delivers the
ds01 daily symbiotic to you monthly and
sustainable packaging with a reusable
glass jar that protects the probiotics
inside and helps minimize plastic use
anyways I actually got a whole package
I get the whole couch I've seen I got
yeah I I know it's awesome and they got
me a sweatshirt did you see it yes did
you get that yes I got it that's why
I've been taking I'm regular I'm ready
to go good health baby it's all about
seed visitc.com hey babe use the code
hey babe to redeem 25 off your first
month of seeds ds-01 daily symbiotic
that's c.com hey babe use code hey babe
start a new healthy habit today
um so I wanted to tell you that I've
been listening to your podcast and I
don't I never did bake the kids brownies
and take it to them while they were
playing little league and have but I did
get you each a gift whoa this is what I
brought you not brownies let's see I
bought you and this is limited this was
like one of a kind so by the way I just
want to tell you right now what this
makes me so happy because it makes me
feel like home because a very New York
mom thing to do is to put a gift for you
in a Ziploc bag it's a very Mom I would
always get [__] in a Ziploc bag I love
it
yeah
wow
this is amazing yes great anniversary
tour connected he's up in there I love
this shirt so much I'm doing the Gutfeld
show today in Fox News I'm wearing this
shirt I swear to God this is I swear I'm
wearing Yolanda I'm rapping Yolanda Vega
on this goddamn show dude forgive me a
lodge receiving in 2025
yes no no he's on his way he looks good
he's lost weight he looks wonderful he
doesn't want to recognize them oh well
there you go well that's what it is
a lot of the beard he had too much beard
he did thank you that's one thing we
always say about something he does a
good job being a beer
[Music]
[Laughter]
Yolanda literally Yolanda you could be
off to the side of an Isis beheading
video and I would just love it there
goes his head
maybe we'll cut that part out
Yolanda I wanted to ask yes dear have
you ever had an besides this podcast
we've ever had an embarrassing encounter
with a fan
like has a fan ever been too much with
the Yolanda in your face like really
with his hot ass breath got because I'm
assuming it's a man yeah see here we go
here we go okay
[Music]
it was for Children's Hospital something
like that and I was the tote call I say
we now have 4 million
was and all these celebrities over there
and if you we had this whole thing to
try and raise money if you call one of
us to donate never pledge blah blah blah
right now well you can talk to one of us
so they were like Yolanda Yolanda you
have a phone call and they were like
they just pledged five thousand dollars
for Yolanda and I was like yeah
yeah so I went up there and I was like
hello they were like Yolanda and I said
Yolanda Vega they were like Yolanda Vega
and I said yes they said will you please
shut up no I hope they're laying in a
dish somewhere he's laughing and I was
like what he was like yes I am so tired
of hearing you and your name and I was
like thank you for contributing have a
great day and I hung up no
I bet you any amount of money that guy's
name was Ralph yeah you
you are
you're a son of a [__] Ralph yeah so
that was a bad thing
to tell you that just to tell
me wow but anyway the kids got the 5G so
right right right right good but now who
is the biggest celebrity who's reached
out to you and been like Yolanda I love
you other than Oprah we know we know
Oprah but anybody else come out of the
woodwork one day and be like especially
with social media now be like Yolanda we
love you no but I got to meet someone
quite recently and he told me that I was
one of the best players he has ever seen
in a long time like a player like like
like like
you crush a lot no I was playing on his
show a game oh okay oh okay okay okay
that's like Family Feud wow
Steve Harvey told me that I was one of
the best fast money Players he's seen in
a long time because I went up there and
let's just say I crushed it number two
then because you're the anchor you went
up first or second I was number one okay
can I I don't like pressure okay okay no
pressure okay we're gonna take we're all
gonna take a guess on what your score
was after the first fast money ran out
it's out of 200 okay right so 200. and
you know that's five questions and it's
uh yeah okay I'm gonna say you
give me one adjective to describe how
well you think you did so I can guess
off that adjective awesome
okay awesome I believe is over 150. I
bet you it's over 150. I'm gonna say
156.
the year she was allegedly born
156 yeah what do you think I'm gonna say
because she's so awesome I'm gonna say
173. oh that's high all right I'm just
saying
173 is high
156 is high if anyone can do it it's
Yolanda you're right you're 100 right
yeah I shouldn't yeah yeah by the way
where's Matt and Matt I noticed you have
to have you have to be married he's not
married to my daughter yeah Jesus also
the Family Feud has a strict no gringos
policy yes
wow pimp
wow that's really good you ready yeah I
don't remember exactly
[Laughter]
it was I believe 176. whoa so myself the
first the first game 76. so then my
partner Rebecca Vega my daughter yes
came in all she needed was 24 or
something like that and we got two we
got twenty thousand dollars
wow how many did she need to get to to
get a chance on the first second don't
matter she had five questions no but I
mean was it tense did it come down to
the Y no she got it on the second one
okay okay okay now this so we won the
first game obviously because we played
for the twenty thousand right so we
played the second game and what the
second game how many points do you think
I was always the first one how many
points you think I got so you won the
second game as well yeah we won the
second game okay so I'm there for Fast
Money how many points you think I got
I'm gonna say still great I'm gonna stay
you still did it upwards of 145 or okay
and I did not oh I did not I tanked in a
second I I did something like 105.
respectable okay and then Rebecca came
in and unfortunately she needed
something like 95 and we didn't win the
fast money oh yeah so that therein lies
the problem I actually have a routine
about this because honestly even when
you win fast money it's 20 Grands
between five adults and it's taxed yeah
less hotel and airfare you're coming on
your dominating you guys are losing a
few hundred dollars no hotel and Fa is
not included it's not even good right
they throw that in for free okay okay
and Rebecca and Rebecca couldn't get she
couldn't get the 95. this is why Matt's
delaying the wedding this is
like 44 not 23. it could be nine myself
to something with the fast money it
could be nine months but wait a minute
but wait a minute so then we played the
third game you won again and we won
again but Rebecca she's such a great
individual I love my baby girl she gave
the opportunity she stepped aside she
said I messed up I'm a step aside so she
gave it to my son-in-law Nick okay tell
me what Nick did here
I'm first up I'm first up and how many
points did you think I gained I I earned
that I think I think you brought it back
I'm gonna say 137.
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say 126.
something like 164. so I went back up
there and all Nick needed was 36 points
and he got it twenty thousand
so then we're on to our fourth game and
a lot happened who who what families are
you leaving in the dust and it's not all
the same day okay and they're various
families family from California
oh this wasn't so in celebrities
no celebrities I'm not a celebrity
regular celebrity family but you don't
have money you got to donate it oh yeah
yeah
like they don't even mention that you're
Yolanda Vega on this family chill Steve
found out who I was because somebody was
from New York in the in the in the
background and said oh my God I want to
take a picture with Yolanda Vega it's
time again to do another drawing all
right
okay yes so South do the honest
that's it three more balls here coming
up yes and this is for the New York
Lotto yes six numbers six numbers oh and
is there one uh like one extra there's
no one okay here we go we'll do Twitter
just bang out three in a row ready yes
what that's okay
okay all right well one is way under
there
number is 33. 33 33. that's a big number
that's the year Jesus died okay
number is
oh my goodness I 33 and five I think
it's closer to me right there
and the last number of hey babe Lottery
is
[Music]
wow and you saw us rolling that yes so
one five six thirty five sixty two and
63. I remembered those that's insane you
remember that those are great numbers
yeah so those are great so we're playing
uh but we will you know we'll see what
happens we'll play and by the way
anybody who does play those numbers and
if they win in your respective State you
are legally obligated to share the money
with us and then we will share with you
Alondra through an LLC so you can play
Lotto yeah because those are six numbers
and you can play Mega because it's five
plus the six and you can play Power
because it's five plus the six right oh
so you go right you can play also the
last no the last the Powerball number
was what six six was the very last
number all right so you could play
choose what you want to play that's the
first batch right there I I gotta be
honest like I feel like there's a
different energy when she draws them
like I'm going to play this time those
are magic balls right there like that
that was our winning numbers they're
winning numbers you know what's sad too
that about today's world Yolanda is my
daughter's gonna grow up in a world
where their Yolanda Vega is going to be
artificial intelligence going to be some
robot I mean and and and you cannot
duplicate the energy Yolanda gives in
this room you can't make her Ai No no
that's that's you know that's one of the
biggest problems actually at the top of
the list now Yolanda what's your
favorite Puerto Rican dish to cook
oh
that I have for your freak I said where
you marinate the chicken with the adobo
and the sauce and you put in the veggies
and the sauce and you make the white
rice on the side but I make a hell of a
black beans
do you like Mofongo I love Mofongo I
don't make mofongo because that's a
Dominican dish so I buy it I don't know
I don't know how to make it for Ralph
but I don't know how to make it yes and
do I like um I love Bethany my husband
Miguel loves Ben needed more okay I love
it what's do you have a go-to Puerto
Rican restaurant in New York City or
Albany or Schenectady no sadly in Albany
there doesn't exist one and in New York
City I just go to wherever I can go
because I my go-to dish is
um the flank steak with onions yes with
black beans and white rice and
Yuca on the side
is better ah you know I love it
platanos are the sweet ones God I want
to have another baby yeah
[Laughter]
did I tell you that I'm gonna go see
your show yes in Albany got the eggs
sold out for anyone else
but you know that you're coming out on
stage and saying you're you know you're
announcing yourself on stage yes 100
that I can't have somebody like Yolanda
beg in the crowd and not invite her up
she's a thousand people she's gonna
bring you out she's going to bring me
out she's gonna say I'm Yolanda Vega and
this is and then as a surprise I'll just
say it here I'll stay here and then the
real plane is we're going to bring out
Ralph blindfolded we're gonna have him
and we're gonna happen
and we're gonna let her do the honors
on a wheel we're gonna spin them we're
gonna give you some knives and a
blindfold and we're gonna see what
happens around he was a really sweet guy
and he got it
no no no I'm just gonna say for the
years that I knew him when he didn't
have a child he was like and I was like
who that you think
and then he had a child a little girl
and she became so sweet so sweet yeah
you're too late he had a little girl he
became so sweet well listen I have two
little girls and I'm like it's really
tough for me to be like a tough guy or
man or anything when it's like you got
these little babies that are little
girls that are just like so sweet and
cute so I get I get but still [__] Ralph
yeah uh yeah so also so he would he
would see you and he knew that he was
making some bank and he knew you were on
on the payroll estate payroll you know
he was a
good actor
did Ralph in any other job ever I don't
know but grapple live can we just look
up Ralph don't say his last name
just Ralph Ralph New York State Lottery
announcer he was in Die Hard with a
Vengeance oh there's a picture of Ralph
and Yolanda in the same room we did
press conferences toward the end of his
contract he would also do press
conferences yes thanks for showing up
Ralph well let me pull that up guess
who's playing Kevin Spacey in the movie
Ralph Ralph looks a little Kevin's face
so do we have any information on him
Yolanda let's let's while we're looking
up information for Ralph I wanted to ask
you Yolanda wow Ralph was around in 2007
holy [__] he was around you if you won
the lotto which now legally you are
allowed to play and win what would you
do with the money after being around for
so long what would you truly do let's
say you won 50 million dollars which
goes a long way I would go to some
beautiful
unnamed exotic island not Epstein's
Island
well to be it's unnamed this goes
against what you said okay okay just
before just know that I we just spoke
about last episode how I don't think
going to beaches in other countries
outside America is worth it because we
have plenty of beautiful beaches here
but go ahead but I would go to an island
somewhere beautiful it could be America
as long as it's my own and I had my
family and my friends there and we had
you know cabana boys and uh and and
pools and water slides and we just had a
good time a good time so it could that
could be in Florida anyway
like that clean and and just do a whole
new renovation there all right okay so
50 million so you'd go but but okay but
all right let's say you do that Yolanda
but that's only what are we spending
there if we're going all out we're
spending what 20 grand 30 Grand Vacation
you're not gonna buy the item I'm
talking about what else are we doing
with it I don't
I just don't like cruises I don't like
ships I don't like boats I don't like
being stuck on a boat so it would not be
oh a cruise with my family and friends
you're not calling anything practical
jokers cruising sounds and there's one
coming up did I tell you about that no
how long does it close for oh when's
this airing when is this
in two weeks well uh we're doing it
again uh Cruise number five they said it
couldn't be and wouldn't be done we're
doing it we're doing it again the
Impractical Jokers number five we are
doing it with a Coke with we're doing it
with somebody else wow Yolanda bacon
will not be there though how many how
many days are you on the water it's uh
four nights five years I could do yeah I
only did one in my life and it was seven
days it was two no two weeks
I like that well helicopter Yolanda in
for one day that's it it's happening and
we're doing it with Eric Andre whoa I
love Eric Andre that's January 22nd to
the 26th of 2024. uh get
shipfacedcrews.com I hope I re-released
this info if I didn't I just I like it
might get in trouble listen what are you
missing this here for your pancakes you
missing your favorite coffee creamer
what with doordash grocery delivery you
get what you want when you need it I
love the convenience of getting what you
want right to my door would you burn
your last pizza toaster avocados go bad
the hot sauce bottle empty well try
grocery delivery from doordash you
trusted should live your restaurant
favorites and now you go to get grocery
delivery that actually delivers too with
thousands of grocery stores to choose
from you'll find the best in your
neighborhood and boost your local
economy with each and every order and
you'll get exactly what you ordered or
they will make it right so just do me a
favor sit back and enjoy your quality of
groceries just like you picked them
yourself yeah you won't even you want
even more value you can save on all your
grocery and restaurant favorites with
the zero dollar delivery fee on eligible
orders with a dash pass your lie
membership let me tell you the dash pass
membership dash pass dash pass
can get 50 AKA 50 off your first
doordash order up to a ten dollar value
when you use code
babe2023 at checkout limited time offer
terms apply that's 50 off up to ten
dollars on a 15 min subtotal and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code babe2023 don't
forget let's go babe 2023 for 50 50 off
your first order with your dash uh I
don't know what the future holds the
stock market is up and down and tanking
and uh I need to keep my business
thriving as you do and if this resonates
with you and you have a small business
and you have shipping needs and ship
station is for you you got to find ways
to save money without cutting Corners
when it comes to saving money as a small
business or every little bit helps and
Chip station gives you access to
discounts of up to 84 off of USPS and
UPS rates and you can manage every order
from one simple to use dashboard and
when you lower your shipping costs and
make returns easy your customers say
stay happy while you save money over 130
000 companies have grown their
e-commerce business with shipstation 98
of companies stick that stick with ship
station for a year become customers for
life that's all you really need to know
I mean make the decision and you get a
nice discount if all you do is go to
shipstation.com use the code hey babe
you sign up for a free 60-day trial it
is free all you gotta do is use that
promo code shipstation.com code hey babe
worry less about the bottom line when
you save money with ships station 60
days free baby
okay it is worth so Yolanda everything's
right with the world you're here maybe
she'd buy a cruise ship with a lot of
money yeah I don't know what I would do
I I just give it to my kids let them do
something that's I'm just chilling I
just chill with my husband
you're a family person which I that's
where like you can feel that energy from
the Orlando she's family first which I
like at what point would you like it
were you like I'm out of here to the
when my baby got my grandson was born
okay my daughter gave birth 8 21 August
2021 and 8 21 21 and when that baby boy
was born I left 222. that was it just
recently I just left 222. you were still
reading the lotto numbers on a year ago
I was behind the scenes so I was the
boss and I didn't want to be on but I
could be okay yeah January actually I
left January 2022. oh my goodness a year
ago when is the last time you read the
lotto numbers on television I have it
somewhere it's probably somebody was out
sick some probably in November of 21.
wow see it must have been that we just
don't watch things anymore it's no what
happened was ABC doesn't put the numbers
and win four down it just puts doesn't
even put lotto and take five on it just
puts Powerball and take five and um and
mega they went with the big they got
something big for their britches so you
were never on T you weren't on TV that
much reading a lot I was all the time
until the concert is every Tuesday every
Tuesday oh I was on every Wednesday and
Saturday because I was doing Lotto but
when I started probably from 92 all the
way to
2012 maybe I was on all the time wow
right and then I delegated yes I chilled
at home with my wine and the and the
young ones stayed up till midnight and
did the drawings wow well she would have
to do it live you were doing that live
too exactly be up at 11 o'clock at night
so at 7 30. it's 7 30 is the numbers
were in four and then the evening
drawing the lotto intake five is at 11.
and you were doing that at 11 o'clock
21. for The Jeffersons which was
syndicated on channel 11. they used to
switch up to watch that and let me tell
you something right now every time you
were on and like you said because we
didn't have DVR we didn't mean every
time you were on my grandmother my mom
would be like shush and they ever it
would be completely quiet and then be
like all right I mean everyone right now
you had to write it down yes yes I
remember that everybody was like be
quiet be quiet you know and sometimes do
we miss a number and then like at the
end they put them up real quick yeah
yeah see that's something people don't
think of it's like it's like when an
actor like wins an award and they're
like oh what a privileged life they must
have it's like well they were away from
their family for six months filming this
movie Yolanda is up at 11 o'clock
getting home at 12 o'clock or her you
know midnight her whole life getting her
kids up for school and having this late
night nocturnal life that people didn't
even think about right and that was at
times I didn't work 24 7. I didn't work
five you know five nights straight till
12. it was a random schedule but I had
the best Little Italian lady that lived
next door to me in Schenectady and she
minded she took care of my newborn and
then the second one my Irish twins for a
long time I needed that because your
husband was working the trooper exactly
he's busy working all kinds of weirdos
she would literally go into your house
to her house that's old school you would
leave at 10 o'clock at night you're
waking up your kids today I would leave
at six at night there was a lot of stuff
that had to be done and come back
wow
through the winter storms up there in
Schenectady Albany and do it all and my
my youngest my my youngest my oldest
daughter Gabriella she was 15 months
when Rebecca was born she didn't walk
till she was 17 months so for two months
I had to carry her and the baby wow and
you know how that is of course
two of us know in the snow and to the
neighbor's house at that see people
don't think about that and we think we
got it hard because we got a podcast and
you're like I gotta go give Millions to
somebody else yeah I gotta get millions
yeah but it was wonderful I would I
would never not do it again I would do
it 100 all over again did you ever have
a time where you got a flat or something
happened and you couldn't get there for
your drawing and someone else had to
cover well I lived in Schenectady and um
there's this hill that I lived off of
the exit and it was snowing a lot and
every time I'm in some sort of accident
car accident it's in the snow so I
called my boss and I said they can't
come in he says you need to come in
who's going to do the joys I said I
can't drive in the snow he came to get
me
Chris I was always there I did my job
right yeah I would say the Chariot for
you yeah
I was even On Top of the World Trade
Center
um in 299 to 2000 because of the big you
know Y2 Y2K thingy and we did the
drawings in Time Square I did a drawing
called Millennium millions in the Good
Morning America studios right and that
was six o'clock in 1999 December 31st
and then prior to that we had done a big
drawing because On Top of the World
Trade Center because we were giving away
a big jackpot was up to I just saw the
commercial 100 yeah you saw me on Top of
the World Trade yes yeah I saw Ralph I
don't know
he was like you probably saw me on top
of the um the Empire State Building I
did that too okay yeah but just someone
so many things it was such a great
career yeah do they have to have an
independent auditor on hand every time
yeah oh and that was just someone from
whatever that used to come back and just
make sure an accounting firm on the up
and up yes wow and how would they do
that they come first and they'd make
sure all the balls were correct and
they'd mix them every month balls are
weighed people don't know this but it
has to be specifically within a in a
millimeter blah blah blah so the
Auditors would go with the uh the
lottery employees and they would weigh
the balls you know and they'd weigh the
balls and make sure everything was on
the up and down maybe this episode is
weigh the balls that's the name of this
episode
yes that meticulous but the auditor was
always Whenever there was a drawing the
auditor was always on set
wow and and who has the patents for the
lotto that Lotto machine
purchase from a company okay whatever
company it's purchased yeah yeah yeah
it's purchased from account I'll tell
you something I never told you and I've
never said it to anybody else okay and
I'm and I said I was thinking that the
karaoke the blood uh thing pictures I
where I was you for Halloween you
yeah
I was you for Halloween in a roughly
2000 mid 2000 oh it's like 2005 to six I
had an outfit I had everything I had the
wig I put everything on I I threw a
party at my bar and I and I was you and
I actually had my friend who's very
handy build me that machine and with a
handle and it worked turned on and
worked and I would I was walking around
holding that machine and while the balls
were going around oh my goodness Yolanda
Vega yelling Yolanda we got to get a
picture of that I have I will find I
will find that photo okay no Yolanda
what who is Yolanda Vega outside the
lotto who's the Yolanda Vega let's go
behind the balls I'm glad you asked that
Chris you're laughing and you want to go
behind the balls but the behind the
balls Yolanda Vega includes balls okay
that's right bigger balls what could be
bigger balls behind the balls yes yes
bigger balls behind the balls yeah
behind the balls bigger balls something
I'm past
one more drawing and then we're gonna
get to it
okay this is the last one there it is
spice it up it's not what's that what's
that the last one oh there I got one
more
how many do you want well we gotta do
we're gonna do I guess one more drawing
right because other than that so you
want three balls we'll do three for now
yeah three for now we'll just keep her
three rules of three that's the rules
I'll tell you about comedy remember the
big boss remember the Big Balls yes okay
I'm thinking about the big balls and
what this means
two 32 the number is 32. all right the
first ball up and the next ball up is oh
there's a story behind this number it's
44. oh
and the last number is
5 4 54. wow all right we're doing it
we're doing this okay
so big balls first let's go big balls
and then let's remember 44. so what's
Big Balls behind the balls you said who
who am I what am I passionate about yes
I'm a big passionate bowler wow
big boy
about 14 pounds
and I bowled twice a week in a league
that's 33 weeks out of the Year
Wednesdays and Sundays passionate about
bowling wow so you won 66 times a year
33 weeks twice a week yes what's the
name of your team it depends because
there's two different teams but I also
Bowl in the summer 13 weeks in the
summer I'm a big time boss how long you
been bowling only since I got married
and when I started bowling my average if
you know about bowling was only 68.
that's horrific yeah that's like a child
and now I'm about a 148 149. oh you got
to spin you got anything I got a hook to
my ball wow and I got this this spray
and it hooks even more with the screen
let me tell you something right now
balls where you're calling yeah boss
with my calling yeah yes isn't that
amazing that's crazy yes balls one way
or another you're gonna get your hands
on those balls
I told you about big ball yes yes Shout
Out Mr Vega
because I love you
all right
that's wonderful names your team names
were
um
Fantastic Fantastic Four on Sunday okay
and in on the Wednesdays it was a
singing group so we were the BG's boys
and girls
like it look at the BG's I played
intramural bowling for uh one year in
high school and our team name was no
frills but I will tell you I like
driving there was three other teams that
all had uh puns like yes lightning
strikes and Strike Force and so we were
just like we'll just do No Frills yeah
and uh we we made it to the playoffs I
don't bowl we made it to the playoffs
and then we made it to a championship
round and then we we lost and then later
it was still when you had to do it by
pencil
we lost and then later someone redid the
cards and there was an error and we
should have won and we never got the
trophy pieces of [__] so we just have a
lot in common would imagine yeah now
what take us to what is the significance
of 44. okay it will come out when I tell
you so we won the first Family Feud we
won the second Family Feud we won the
third Family Feud we won 20 000 did not
win twenty thousand so now we're playing
the fourth game okay we play the fourth
game and we have an amazing time and we
win so I'm the person to do the first
fast money and I think I got something
like 70 something I was I was not good
and Nick had to come out and get 120
something and he ended up getting our
final score was you know you have to get
200 right yeah 199.
but you do get five dollars per point so
we ended up getting something like a
thousand we got like a thousand dollars
for that okay yeah man that was the
fourth game okay so we won forty
thousand dollars already now here's the
fifth and final game you you ran the
whole week we ran we kept winning and if
you win five games you win the car so
this is our last time okay so our last
time what was the car Wait the car was a
Jeep fancy Jeep or whatever but there's
a story behind that okay so anyway
anyway so the last question it came down
to the very last question the last
question was what does a pioneer woman
have
a good pair of a pioneer woman that was
the question so we were lacking we were
lacking but we were stealing a lot and
here they had
270 something and we had something like
I don't know 120 something by the way
everybody knows the third round is is is
the first two rounds don't matter
the third round is triple points that's
what you're making a break and the
fourth I was in fourth position that's
quadruple points but anyway so here we
are and this is the final thing
Here's the final thing and we said we
said stockings because my niece Margie
came up with that
Pioneer Woman has a good pair of a good
pair of and and and and we came up with
the ancest stockings and then guess what
it came up and we won and we were
hysterical because we won the money and
there it is look there we go we won the
monk we won the car we won the car no we
didn't play fast money yet because fast
money is after but you're in the car
even though we're not fast money right
you win five games right right right
right so we won the car we were
hysterical so now they had trained us so
now we're running to the car and there's
Nick and Gabriella and Rebecca and
Yolanda and Anna Margie my niece and
we're running to the car and then we get
to the car and he's laughing because he
can't believe we got it we got it we got
it five days so I guess I know a good
pair of and I get in my seat and
everybody's hysterical we want the money
so now we won the money and cut and it's
over so they get us out the car we go
back down we get because we got to do
Fast Money the last thing in the last
fast money I got something like 160
something or 150 something and no wait
wait wait wait one
56 okay right 156. so how much is needed
to win the car to end the 20 000. 40 44.
so my daughters are there and that's my
daddy he's in heaven that's his favorite
number four four forty four so my
daughter Rebecca turns to me and she
says
yeah and my dad December that this is
crazy yes yes I can't believe we're like
related no I know so you're like my
brother 44 in college
so Rebecca tears to me and she says 4-4
Grandpa's number all we need is four
four Grandpop in heaven and he got 45 or
something when we won the twenty
thousand oh no yes
yes did you take the cash payout for the
card did you take the action so so
Rebecca always said she was gonna get
the car because Rebecca is the one that
about the whole idea of putting me on
Family Feud because it was my retirement
party because I didn't want to party I
don't like parties
it was my retirement present from
Rebecca and my daughter Gabriella so
Rebecca always said she was going to win
the cop but when push came to shove they
don't offer you the car they give you 25
000 equivalent so they took 60 something
thousand plus the extra money so we won
like 62 000 475 plus another 25 000. we
want like 86 000 all together wow
divided by five and then they mail you
the check which we haven't gotten yet
how many years ago we just did it
February 2nd of this year and 90 days
after which is May 2nd they're supposed
to send you your money so you so they
better this week coming up next week
they better
again
hey you not from us winning the lotto
and secretly
that's what four four means
it's beautiful one last time one last
time
we're gonna do one last drawing and
that's all she wrote folks this has been
Yolanda vegan hey babe hey babe I mean
we I feel like one of those Lottery
balls yes
exactly
and hey babes number two is
eight a number eight which is also not
her age
and finally the last ball this will be
her age it is yeah 56.
it's the year my mother was born
all right well
rounds of winning lottery numbers right
there we cannot say it was amazing about
you we love you to pieces you did not
disappoint that felt like it was five
minutes you were the best that's amazing
and then we've gotten you a bus ticket
back disconnecting
and I thank you for that no it really
was amazing we're gonna see you in
Albany and then Sarah will be in Albany
and Sal will see Yolanda again yeah no
this is not the end of the big barbecue
yeah yeah I want to hang out with you
guys more than this this is amazing and
maybe we'll have cocktails oh come on
how about this you ready for this let's
get drunk and go bowling yeah
I would say I have had an amazing time
so for hey babe now and forever I am
your London Vega good luck everyone
wow
[Applause]
uh
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey